il ya trois mois encore il ne se
parlaient plus et c'est peu dire donc
c'est avec cette médiatrice qu'ils ont
crevé l'abcès y surtout qu'ils ont
compris ce qui leur est arrivé
c'est pur vont se retrouver tout
s'enchaîne beaucoup mais ni plus par
téléphone en quatre ans écrit a
transcrit par lettre recommandée
on va plus chercher les recommandés donc
tout tout tout dégénère
les enfants de toute façon nous ré je me
ce conflit quatre ans de guerre sans
n'est que le tour de la garde des
enfants
un juge les a mis au pied du mur et les
a contraints à venir se parler dans ce
sens cette séance en trois mois ce
qu'ils n'espéraient plus est finalement
produit
on va commencer à rediscuter et puis à
partir de là les choses sont venues très
vite derrière on s'est rendu compte que
c'étaient des boots où l'on n'était pas
d'accord pour une bêtise mais mentir et
qu' il fallait pas grand chose il
fallait prendre grand-chose pour chacun
fasse un pas là on est arrivé finalement
à faire en sorte de prendre les
décisions sont plaisants on souhaite
impliquer à les détacher leur enlever ce
ce fardeau qui qui qui pesait sur eux
ils se sont mis d'accord pour héberger
les enfants en alternance mais bien plus
encore c'est toute la vie de ces mêmes
enfants qu'ils auront défini tout est
couché sur papier l'école la santé les
loisirs les vêtements et que sais-je
encore
rien n'est laissé au hasard un accord
rendu possible sans doute parce qu'ici
on peut tout dire sans être jugé
on ne fait partie ni de la justice ni du
corps médical ni de tout ce qu'est le
psy choses etc ni justice et ça c'est
important
ce qui se dit à l'intérieur du bureau du
médiateur ne sortira jamais du bureau du
médiateur
c'est peut-être cela la raison du succès
en un an les médiations ont augmenté de
30% à la demande des juges ou des
couples eux-mêmes